we're going to begin this hour with the
first ustv interview with the family of
Harry Dunn since an American pled guilty
to causing his death in England we've
been following the story for the from
the very beginning and it's been a very
tough heartbreaking story to all of us
last week Ann sakulis admitted that she
did strike and kill Harry Dunn while
driving her car near an Air Force Base
back in 2019. the 19 year old Dunn was
riding his motorcycle something he used
to do all the time and prosecutors say
that's the coolest was driving on the
wrong side of the road for three years
Dunn's family has tried to force sakulas
to return to England after she fled the
country and claim diplomatic immunity
now according to her lawyers sakulis was
working for U.S intelligence agency at
the time of the crash we're joined Now
by Harry's parents that's Tim Dunn and
Charlotte Charles we welcome you back to
the table so much has happened guys in
the last three years and it didn't seem
that this day would ever come but she
has pled guilty she's going to be in a
court next next month in England and
she's supposed to be in in the court
how are you all preparing for the
possibility that you might actually see
her face to face we're having a lot of
therapy right now we started it some
time ago it's becoming more intense now
knowing that we may have to face her
face to face you know we agreed for this
process to be done remotely so that she
could stay in the U.S
we're all for technology and Innovation
so it it felt okay for us to do that so
it was
audible gasps all around the court when
the judge in London said that she had to
come back for sentencing I know and what
did you think about that too I mean she
had to come back for a sentence like
Charlotte said was I was completely
shocked I was not expecting that we were
just expecting that it would be done
remotely like the trial had been sorry
the court appearance had me
um and it was just like the pit of my
stomach was just like shock and
disbelief
um struggle to breathe and then you know
it was well it was amazing and also
scary it was just because I didn't think
I'd ever meet this lady to be honest and
then to realize to see her face to face
to him I don't know how to answer that
girl really I
I suppose I should but whether I could
actually do it and keep my emotions in I
don't know you know guys the thing that
has always touched me about this case is
in the beginning Charlotte you said I
don't even want her to go to jail no I
understand that this was a terrible
terrible accident and if she had just
said something to you in the very
beginning you're saying we wouldn't even
know your names you told me absolutely
and we still stand by that you know it
didn't need to be where we are now you
know saying sorry would have been part
of it but you know your your rules in
the US are very similar to ours in the
UK you know whether you kill somebody
intentionally or unintentionally as Ann
sakula said you know accountability
still needs to be had you can't just
simply decide to walk away and and
expect us to to move move forward as a
family we'd lost everything we'd had
everything taken from us yes but
absolutely from the beginning we said
that we didn't want to separate her from
her children she's a mother too she's a
mother of three and
you know we still stand by that and the
the judge has made it very clear
in court in London on Thursday that the
main way that ansakulus could show her
most amount of remorse is by returning
to the UK for sentencing and judge made
it very clear that her the likeliness of
having a jail sentence imposed is is
very very slim so she could literally
just you know come over get this done
that should have been done three years
ago and come home to her children the
judge said that she could get on the
plane and fly home come right home
because you said Tim this is not about a
British versus American thing this isn't
what this is for you no what is it for
you it basically it's like Charlotte
said it's just right and wrong it's just
it's just human nature that you can't
take a life and not answer for that you
know it's just nothing to do with UK us
it's just unfortunate that's how it's
panned out it's always been about doing
the right thing for
for doing something as we said she
didn't mean to do it but you must answer
we all agree it wasn't yeah yeah yeah
she just needs to to take the
accountability you know in court on
Thursday was the right step forward
you know we knew that we would get to
that point we had no idea
what a battle it would be you know we've
got no idea deep down how much damage
it's done to our mental health to fight
for the three years that we have but
it's Harry was worth it yeah he's still
worth it as everybody's loved ones are
you know they all deserve justice and
we're you know we got there on Thursday
we just need to get this last night done
to be grieving while also fighting is
going to be a difficult uh two-step but
one of the things that is going to
happen at the sentencing hearing is your
side of the table will have an
opportunity to address the court and to
address and it's the coolest I know
you're getting to the point of thinking
about seeing her face to face have you
also begun to think about what you might
say what words you want her to hear
we've prepared a victim
statement a victim impact statement
we've had help from our therapists and
our advisor rad Sieger with that it's
um
going to be extremely difficult for me
to read
hence the amount of therapy that I'm
going to need between now and then
because it's very important to me
for everybody to hear how yeah hard and
we would all love to hear from answer
coolers because I would imagine listen I
know this was an accident for this woman
and I think we would all love to hear
her say something about how she's
feeling and how she has dealt with this
you know you had said that the main
point that you want to make is this has
always been about Harry but you've also
received a big outpouring from people
here in this country you know we were
the first place you came when you did
the interview I still remember that
interview talking to you all and you
received a big out point of support from
Americans here as well right we did I
mean we we wouldn't be here without all
of the support from from the US and
indeed around the world but coming here
on your show three years ago next week I
think it is you know really gave us the
platform to be able to say look you know
we're we're a good family we don't mean
any harm
that parents deserve justice for their
son you know we miss Harry every minute
of every day the pain that you have to
live with is
there's not enough words in the English
dictionary to describe that and the
support that we have had from the media
here in the US and and your viewers yeah
it's just been incredible and we just
thank them so much at the bottom of us
apart without you guys you really have
helped us the media and the American
public have been fantastic I remember
the first show we've done like we talked
about I think we're working walking out
in the first block we had two people
come up to us and say you know and give
us a hug
people honestly that's so true and it
was just it was it was just we just
broke down it was just unbelievable but
it's just a matter of doing the right
thing a simple apart not a simple
apology but an apology makes such a
difference in your healing process thank
you thank you both thank you so much